foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
going to talk about you right in front
of you Jade warshaw Ramsey personality
is my co-host today and uh Jade and I
have both spent the morning uh working
on uh what a whole bunch of you are
working on because we're working on it
to try to help you a bunch of you are up
against it that's right the um you you
were on the phone talking with Newsweek
this morning about student loans yeah
the the interest is started right
newsweek's saying anything intelligent
you know they I think they start to see
that the the IDR these payment plans are
not all that they seem to be and so they
wanted to know is this really the best
path forward
and of course you know I told him the
truth yeah
[Laughter]
real plainly so that even they could
understand it oh yeah they understood it
that's good and then we spent uh working
with our content team working out the
talk that Jade and Rachel and I will be
doing on September the 12th the student
loan live stream how we got here and
what to do about it it's a completely
free live stream did I mention it's free
shut up it's free sign up for it go to
ramseysolutions.com student loans but
we're talking about what are some of the
solutions since we're Ramsay Solutions
and we know that here's what we do know
we know that a whole bunch of folks are
scared
angry yeah and rightfully so they were
lied to shocking your government didn't
tell you the truth who knew and they're
confused and Confused yeah because we
found you know we're talking about this
yesterday I guess it was or you and I
maybe earlier in the week the
um one quarter of the 40 million that's
16 million people uh have a student loan
their processor changed their service
are changed during the three-year period
of time so they don't even know where to
pay their payments so you're getting
ready to be behind and don't even know
why and uh I was just meeting with our
friends at y refi we were having lunch
together and they were teaching me
something about the private student loan
side yes and the private student loans I
did not realize this are almost all
variable interest rates yes so guess
what
you got a problem too your interest
rate's been soaring it's been going up
the interest rate going Jack Jack Jack
Jack Jack Jack well if you got federal
student loans are getting ready to go
smack smack smack smack in the face so
you know you got to deal with this stuff
now why refi can help you do that of
course with a refinance and reset the
whole thing and that's a whole different
story but that's one of the solutions
yes that's right that's why we put you
know we're real careful about who we put
on as an Advertiser with like our voice
on it and stuff because man you guys
trust us and we don't want to screw that
trust thing that's right so anyway check
those guys out but be sure and sign up
for this live stream whether you got
private whether you've got public
student loans we're going to talk about
it I get it
but let me just tell you spoiler alert
no easy way out nope you made a big
freaking mess you're gonna get you a
shovel and you're gonna have some
calluses when you're done with your
shovel and here's the thing even if you
don't have student loans you know
somebody that has student loans and they
need this live stream and you need to
share it with them they're scared yeah
they're mad yeah you can you can really
step in and help them
I mean the sad ones are the ones that
are still wait gonna wait around on the
government to fix it well let me tell
you about what I heard recently Dave
what they're telling you you're gonna
make me mad I'm about to make you real
mad so the latest thing in the show
you're gonna make me mad the latest
thing is they're calling it a 12-month
on-ramp
where you don't have to make payments
for 12 months starting today and the
interest will accrue of course but we
won't tell the credit companies
that you're defaulted
in other words we're gonna lie yeah
yeah so your FICO score is getting lied
to to help you with your little FICO
score meanwhile you are getting sucker
punched up again so let me just tell you
let me help you with this banks are not
your friend no you don't need to you
don't need me to figure this out and
these student loan servicers have one
goal keep you in debt as long as I can
because they are blood sucking freaking
parasites they're a tick on your butt
they want you to do something with it
they want your payment they don't want
your piece period oh that's almost like
a jade line in there let's keep it let's
keep going but what's your payment they
don't want your piece people forget
peace we don't want your payments that's
right we're the opposite y'all got to
remember student loans this is big
business okay what these payment plans
they're products intended to make money
off of you don't forget it now if you
watch borrowed future the documentary
that was award-winning that we did one
of the things on there is a navient
employee yeah uh of course all blacked
out because they didn't want to hit us
in the hit squad after her but she she
relays how they were taught to mess up
the phone call to aggravate the borrower
so that the borrower would just hang up
and never make payments continue to
accrue late charges continue to accrue
interest it was an an intentional
incompetence yes and if I don't piss you
off bad enough to get your act together
and pay these people off I'm telling you
you know one of the things has to happen
to get out of debt you got to get mad
you got to get so mad Dave you had 200
65 000. yes and you and you and Sam got
mad we 280 000 and I got pissed I'm
sorry I got pissed off because I'm like
you're getting hammered you're getting
hammered and there's it's the
disillusionment right you come out of
college you're like I did everything
right I got my degree I did and then you
got these loans and it's like oh wait
you didn't understand compound interest
you didn't understand what happens when
you put the loan in forbearance you
didn't understand the loan had to be
paid back
yeah that's not a loan not a grant I
told somebody the other day I said we
had five big old loans a lot of them
were private loans with the variable
interest rate and the payments combined
were two thousand dollars a month I
don't know a month that's just that
takes my breath away yeah well you know
we gotta folk out there right now in
that exact same situation and we can
show them some help that's right student
loan live stream student loan debt in
America how we got here and how to get
out yeah and that's ramseysolutions.com
student loans to sign up for free
doesn't cost a thing Rachel Cruz and
Jade will be there I'll be there just to
I'm kind of there just to piss you off
and then they're going to teach you so
but it's kind of well it's my it's my
spirit that's right that's right you
gotta function in your gifts so uh yeah
student loan livestream
ramsesolutions.com whether you got
private whether you got public we're
going to give you some ideas and some
things to do to you know because we're
learning more and more and more about
the how dark the private side is like
you were just talking about the with
from the guys at y refi why refi that's
one of our advertisers on here and again
they're really what they are in this
case this type of Advertiser is a
partner that's great these are people
that we say Hey you need some help these
guys can help he was telling me about a
guy at lunch fifteen thousand dollars in
debt hadn't paid on it for a bazillion
years irresponsible of course runs up to
145 000. I know about that uh-huh you
did I know about that all right what was
yours our started at Let's see we had
one that started at
let me go because we have five of them
so one started at seven thousand by the
time I started paying it it was nine
thousand we had one that was
91 to 128 000. okay yeah and you didn't
let it go that long this gotta let it go
a long time anyway they were able to do
a refinance with that guy wow and get it
weighed get his payment from like two
thousand down to six hundred so this is
what we need you know that's that's nuts
yeah yeah see the actual Solutions not
vague fake promises from fake fake
people in Washington DC you know who you
are this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Alyssa is with us in Los
Angeles hi Alyssa welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um I was calling
as I go into law school
you've been accepted
uh no I right now I am pursuing my
bachelor's in political science but I do
want to be able to save as much as
possible before I see Crystal law school
I did get accepted into a university for
political science good okay all right
what year are you in school
first
or second he's coming out of high school
heading that way good good for you
a little bit post High School yeah okay
good yeah well
um here's what's interesting
I have hired
um more lawyers than I want to count
over the 30 years of doing business and
I've yet to ask one where they graduated
from
got it so there are a few times uh being
a Harvard
attorney of law was studied at Harvard
Law or Yale will matter but uh only
about one or two percent of the
transactions in the world care
so most attorneys make their living
on people that don't care where you
graduated from very few care about the
famous schools right that's so true so
and you know the reason the only reason
to bring that up is price
so where you get your law degree how you
get it for that matter doesn't matter as
much as that you actually learn the law
right exactly that's so good and so the
currency here is knowledge the currency
is not the uh the famous School
uh so I'm going to go at law school like
that to start with because law school is
not unlike undergraduate work and the
number one reason for student loan debt
is college Choice meaning you chose one
you couldn't afford
and so I you know uh I I don't know what
that is in your situation in California
uh I don't know how you study law there
where the quote cheap law school is
unquote but I just first thing I want to
do is encourage you to not be afraid of
that that it will stench your career or
something because it just really won't
that's true my brother's a lawyer and he
went here locally in Nashville I think
it's called Nashville School of Law he's
a lawyer he went on to be a common judge
High School yeah and he went to night
school I did not know that that's a
famous law school by the way there's a
lot of big time people went to that
night school got their law degree went
on into politics went into like that
thing they're it's it's weird and it's
very inexpensive it's very inexpensive
and it did not stunt his career at all a
matter of fact he has gone on to do one
like I said he's a judging Williamson
County now so it's it's great I didn't
know we had I didn't know I had a judge
in Williamson County that I could call
all right now you got one George I need
a judge now I know where I got one okay
that's right not that he would
necessarily do anything but yeah that's
what I would tell you to do I would tell
you to do something like that number one
number two uh I want you to start
studying and thinking about it number
three uh you could consider uh things
like a military service option and
serving the Jag core for a while when
you come out uh and free law degree they
pay for it uh you could uh you know the
uh um National Guard has a ten a twenty
thousand dollar stipend that they will
pay if you join the National Guard for
any
any degree field you know that's a
really good
um
gauge to see how interested you are
because those military programs both for
Law and medical are great on-ramps to
see like okay how can I do this for the
most cost effective way and if it's like
I don't I want to do it but I don't want
to do it like that I don't want to be
trapped for four years well try
borrowing 250 000 you're going to be
trapped for two yeah in a different kind
of way yeah there's a different kind of
trap so uh I mean I you know the the uh
you guys are wanting to study to be
Pilots the Army Air National Guard or
the Air National Guard rather uh oh my
gosh yeah uh this is how you get you
don't spend 200 150 000 to become a
pilot and make 35 000 a year your first
year flying puddle jumper that's right
which is what happens no you go join the
stinking service and they pay for it
that's the deal so something along those
lines Alyssa because the first thing
you've got to do with the debt equation
where everyone's doing that is you have
to take it off the table and say not an
option now what do I do not going is an
option but not but borrowing is not an
option now what do I do how do I figure
this out how do I how do I finagle how
do I find scholarships that are
scholarships are unusual for law school
but they can be found how do I find
fellowships they're unusual but they can
be found and of course if you don't know
what a fellowship is in this case a PhD
program Med program law school program
you you end up being a proctor you end
up working as a grad student you work
for the University they pay you 15 20
000 a year but your tuition's free
that's right that's and you know and you
work your tail end off well I don't know
if I yeah well you're going to work your
tail end off at some point either pay
them back the 250 000 debt or doing
something like this so just decide when
it is you're going to work your tail end
off yep you gotta choose your hard pay
yeah choose your own paper you're gonna
pay a price to win baby that's the plan
so that's what I would tell you to do
just keep scratching around the areas
like that where you go to school
consider something like Nashville law
that's a night school approach that kind
of a thing fellowships if you can find
them scholarships if you can find the
military service if you can find them
none of these sound overly Pleasant
but neither does 250 000 in student loan
debt
because you're going to wake up one day
like all these folks are waking up right
now with October 1 barreling down on
them and they're going to be going oh
crap you're gonna have that old crap
moment I just the older version of me is
really pissed at the younger version of
me and you want to go out and be a
lawyer and just practice law
XYZ right
it'd be nice to just work you choose a
different place to work yes because you
don't have to work over with those
twerps that's right that pay more that's
right you work because you want to work
you work at the place you want to work
at Chris is in Ohio hi Chris what's up
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
hey I had a quick question uh I've heard
you talk a lot about retirement and
different retirement accounts um but
I've never heard you address pensions
so uh I I'm a fireman and we are in a
pension system that I essentially at 25
years and the age of 52 you can retire
with a 60 of your top five years great
and it's not optional it's mandatory
because you get one and a half percent
why I don't address it you don't have a
choice if you're going to be a fireman
you're going to do that so what's your
question
my question is
457. sure and that's a Roth option
should I be doing something other than
that
yeah I mean look the pension is going to
take care of you
maybe shorter 60 of you right assuming
they don't screw up the pension and mess
it up which most of the time they don't
but there's some of them get really
sideways so I'm not going to count on
someone else take care of me I want a
big old pile of money over here to take
care of me and I want to take care of
mine
a Godly Man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children
I I want to change my family tree and so
your 457 your 401k your Roth I with your
matches the compound interest and good
mutual funds there that's all about
piling up cash to help others maybe not
just to make sure you eat I think you're
gonna eat
because of your service to the community
and I think that's great
okay but I mean well thank you I
appreciate that yeah retire with five
million dollars instead of nothing
well it used to be in some cases your
pension could die with you it does well
is it do you think that that's all it
does there for sure oh definitely well
that's enough that right there is enough
reason to make sure his pension is for
him yeah but you've got you know spouse
you've got kids you got grandkids you
got the community I want to impact and
turns out starving kids in the community
hungry babies in the community they get
fed by people that have money yeah not
broke people and so go get you some
money so you can be of good in this
world and that that's what being
generous and that's so this is all about
how to build wealth in addition to
taking care of meat bench and take care
of you pretty good I mean 60 is okay
it's not like you're going to be living
high on the hog or something but no I'd
want more money
you would yeah I'll take more Alex
definitely more more for Jade Alex more
for Jade
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
okay watch all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly has local
service providers to repair maintain and
improve your home their network of
experts offers top quality work and
customer service by trained reliable
service providers these are good people
uh find the help you need at
neighborly.com today all right today's
question comes from Thomas in Colorado
he says I'm struggling to know how much
we actually need to retire I'm 54 and
currently have 1.4 million in a 401k
which sounds like a lot to me but I
don't actually know how fast we'll burn
through that what's the best way to know
how much I'll actually need so I'm
thinking about your the goal you don't
want to burn through your nest egg right
you want to have it invested in such a
way that you're able to live off of the
interest and not really touch the nest
egg is what I would say
um so that would be my first thought is
I would use a calculator and kind of run
this back and go okay what is what's the
income that I think I'm going to need
and get that number and then okay what
does the draw off of my interest need to
be what does my nest egg need to be so
that my draw can equal that so I'm kind
of reverse engineering it in that way
um and then there's also the part of
this you know you're 54. I'm thinking
okay you've got 1.4 million now there's
a good chance that in seven years it
could double and that ain't bad yeah if
you've got it invested at 10 percent or
better it doubles every seven years yeah
ten percent or better yeah so it's 61 if
you're invested in good mutual funds
you're going to have uh 2.8 and at 68
you know you're gonna have five and a
half million dollars now there is
inflation to play into that no I'm just
talking about no I'm not talking about
inflation I'm just saying that if you're
if you're making 10 it doubles every
seven years a lump sum does that's if
you're adding nothing to it okay so at
68 that's what you would have if you
don't touch this now if you got to
retirement and all you had was 1.4
million then the way you how would you
calculate if that's enough just like
Jade said there's a couple of factors
there's inflation uh that you want to
stay away from and you need to look at
your rate of return so if you're
invested in good growth stock mutual
funds that are averaging what the stock
market has averaged the stock market is
averaged 11.8 percent since it began the
standard and poor okay
so let's just pretend you're making 11
we'll round down for the people that go
bananas when I start talking about this
stuff all right so we're gonna round
down you're making 11 all right if you
left three in there
that would so that it would grow a
little bit to cover some inflation and
pulled off eight uh that means you'd be
living on ninety thousand dollars a year
eight percent one point four right with
no debt yeah and so can you do that
that's the question and if you can do
that in today's dollars you can do that
in tomorrow's dollars because if you
leave this alone because it will have
grown that much more that's right all
right and so if you did that the account
is growing by three percent a year if it
averages an 11 rate of return also good
point so you're still getting your money
never burns up it runs in perpetuation
it's a perpetual motion machine and this
is another good time to bring in why we
think it's and teach that it's so
important to be debt free with a paid
for Helm at retirement because you don't
need any bills you don't need as much
money to live on yeah and then it keeps
you from doing this but let's say you
start stepping on it okay and you step
on the principle a hundred thousand
dollars a year
when are we going to start that at 70
that takes you to 84. so you're not
going to run out of money if you just if
you look at your burn rate on your
principal as well so you're going to be
fine you've done a great job now the
trick is what I would suggest is we keep
earning a living and leave this money
alone and let's let it double A couple
more times before we start uh then then
you can pull off you know 200 000 a year
that's right I mean you're sitting on
five million instead of one million it's
a whole different equation dude and so
and again good growth stock mutual funds
we suggest uh I split my personal 401K
Jade does two uh among four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international and over the last 30 years
my little portfolio of that has averaged
over 12 most years over 13 percent wow
Dave that's great
I mean it's not really hard to beat the
s p the s p is the average of the market
so what do you want to be I always kind
of want to be above over a pillow you
know I mean that's you know try to beat
it a little bit but you know you stay in
that north of 10 and you draw in that
seven or eight range you're gonna bump
up and cover inflation as you go along
now uh you know some of the wonky uh
Certified Financial Pharisees types you
know they go bananas on that calculation
but here's the thing I try to get people
to remember is when we've done studies
of people that win with retirement none
of them won with retirement because of
some nuanced understanding of 12 B1 fees
or some discussion about Point 11.8
versus 12.3 or 10.2 that none of that
caused them to retire well will cause
them to retire well is they actually put
money in the freaking
401K there's a high correlation between
people that have money and people that
save money why is this hard that's so
good it's not a bunch of freaking Theory
you've got to do it and oh my God you
nerds drive me bananas but so yeah just
it's good to be thoughtful about things
but it's sometimes sometimes you just
gotta do something you know just run up
and knock the crap out of something well
what if you're a person that's like Dave
I just I just invest in my you know my
index funds that's fine I I don't want
to get into all this stuff I just want
to do my index funds that's fine you're
just average
you're just average average return
you're a c student
not a c student well that's what average
isn't it you're not failing but nobody's
looking at you you're driving a lot of
money on the table Yeah you left some
money out there that's okay I just want
to beat it just because it's a game you
know I don't care and by the way none of
that is what's making me wealthy what's
making me wealthy is the fact I'm
actually investing
you actually put money in over time over
the Long Haul it's a habits the you know
we saw these millionaires we go okay did
you know was it the rate of return that
made you a millionaire no what major
millionaire every month I put money in
for 27 years and now I got 2.8 million
dollars they're just a tortoise it's
just like one step ugly tortoise ugly
tortoise ugly tortoise we need to print
up tortoise t-shirts
you can wear that one Dave
whoa
my wife slamming my fashion choices here
you don't like my tortoise t-shirt I'll
let you wear it and then we'll point to
we'll just point to it on you just point
to the toys
the little pudgy tortoise that could now
you said that part not me
oh gosh open phone's a triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Jennifer's in Philadelphia hi Jennifer
what's up
hi Dave hi Jane how are you better than
we deserve how can we help
um so my question is should I
eyeliner on I have
I know this is bad okay how old is she
she's 25. okay is she paying the bill
occasionally no she's paying it but it's
late every month so you're getting
dinged every month
every month now the good thing is my
husband and I are Consumer Debt free as
of August 1st what's the balance on This
Disaster
um under 3 000. pay it off instantly
write a check today and pay it off it's
causing you more heartache than it is
three thousand dollars and I can tell
you got a little money don't you
Jennifer
oh yeah we've got a uh emergency fund
we've got a savings account we're
investing yes good pay it off and and
and just set her free okay here's what
you're telling don't tell her she owes
us no no no no no no no no Thanksgiving
dinner tastes different when you eat
with your master don't do that no I just
let her go it's just three thousand
dollars what I would tell her is listen
you made a huge mistake borrowing on a
car and I made a huge mistake helping
you both of us were stupid please don't
be stupid again because I promise you I
won't be that's such a good point this
is a teaching this is a teaching moment
and it's good for her to see that you
learned a lesson too that you'll never
do again and now she can learn a lesson
too that she'll never do but you need to
have a real clear message don't become
knocking on the door for one of these
again it ain't happening again
no it will well but so here's the other
thing is she owes me eleven thousand
so this is an ongoing pattern between
you two so it was but I have recently
broken I've she's now what does she make
uh
ten dollars an hour Let Her Go Let Her
Go God's sakes don't loan family members
money and don't loan people money that
you love unless you want them to Hate
You Don't Own them money
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade wildshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host Kyle's in Tampa Florida hey Kyle
what's up
hey Dave hey Jade thanks so much for
taking my call sure how can we help
hey so I recently went through a divorce
and trying to decide whether it's time
to sell my house as I face this next
chapter in my life I'm sorry
yeah thanks how long were you married
10 years
yeah and you got the house and the
divorce
yeah so so I make 61 000 a year I'm on
baby step two with a debt of thirty four
thousand dollars and um that's all the
result of the separation so it's IRS
that from a mistake a couple years back
uh credit card personal loan and yeah so
as part of the settlement um I got to to
keep the house but I have to pay my ex
out forty seven thousand dollars flat
within 18 months so basically I've kind
of got like a two-year I guess you call
it a moratorium just kind of a breeze on
it and I got reimbursed for the time
that she wasn't in the home so today the
house is worth about 290 we owe um about
135. so I'm I've been running some
scenarios just some different budgets
and I and I think if I were to sell it
today you know uh rather than in two two
years in in 18 months if I were to sell
it I could pay off all the Consumer Debt
the the thirty four thousand I could pay
her the 47 000 and have a fully funded
emergency fund of six months and still
have twenty to thirty thousand dollars
to start on a future down payment it
would just mean that I'm renting for a
season and so you know it feels like a
one step backwards to just take three
steps forward and I'm just kind of
asking them I'm on the right track
thinking that way I just I just don't
know that I can afford it anymore I can
afford the mortgage payment but I'm not
going to be able to afford it by the
time I have to pay her out and I think
just slow dripping the debt I'm on a
tight budget as it is and while being
able to afford air travel because we
have two kids and it's a long distance
agreement that involves fights and so
it's uh I'm just wondering if the reset
button is the way to go you know well
you've got to give her the 47 000 no
matter what in two years so it's not
like you have the option not to
you can refinance
and just get right and get hers out yeah
the refinance would be tough I mean I'm
in my rate that you know 3.8 to
refinance would basically double that
and I'm not suggesting that I understand
that's the only other option other than
sell because you can't cash flow 47 to
Jade's point
right and we were normal and broke and
we got into a 30-year loan anyway I'm
not even in a 15 years so I'm like can I
actually afford it anyway I'm wondering
should you know by renting it it's just
certainly there's a lot of reasons to
sell the house is there any reason to
keep it
not really to be honest I I dream about
the peace and maybe the emotional break
from it you know like what would that
look like you know it's just that you
got voices in your life your real estate
agent and everyone in between you know
you can't sell the house you can't you
know and it's going yeah but I know the
numbers guys you know what about kids
are there they're they're out of town
he's having to travel so there's no but
I guess I'm saying that they don't have
an attachment to the house that you're
feeling like oh I gotta keep this stable
for them not not really I I did in the
short term because you know
um basically you know it's it's holidays
and summer you know I've got them about
35 of the year and it's it's you know
the flying back and forth and so they're
not really emotionally attached to it
necessarily but well whatever they were
left when their mother took them to
another stage so I
I'm of the Mind
reasons to sell it and then maybe you're
renting for a while as you're stacking
up money and just having a fresh start
fresh slate you're clear of the debt uh
which by the way how much IRS debt was
it because I want to get that out of
there as quickly as possible yeah it's
it's a it's a it's a eight thousand
dollars yeah of that 34 as IRS I'm
putting the house on the market this
week brother
wow okay I do it immediately don't don't
get any closer to Thanksgiving and
Christmas let's get it on the market and
get sold this fall and um
um you know I predict relief yeah yeah
well you you you you're the math of it
you spent the entire call selling us on
selling the house you really do want to
sell it and I really don't blame you I
don't hear any reason to keep it uh long
term you want to be a real estate owner
long term you want to own your home
short term uh you need to clean up your
dad gum mess and put all this hurt and
pain and the associated mathematics with
the hurt and pain all in the rear view
mirror and be driving off into the
sunset into a new Wonderful Life
and um that gives you the ability to do
that yeah let's
let's rebuild from a strong a point of
strength not from a point of weakness
and that you know building your the next
chapter of your life it is a new
chapter
it makes a difference thanks for the
call uh Jennifer's in Sacramento hi
Jennifer how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um so our AC compound recently in the
midst of 100 degree weather and we're
wondering how do we budget for this
while we're trying to pay off all our
debts okay conked out is not a technical
term what happened to it
in a new system so says the guy trying
to sell you a new system where's the guy
that'll patch the leak because you're
broke hey let me put this in words that
you can and my parents
now I would never suggest that but I'm
just telling you repairs can be made is
all I'm saying
okay yeah so cheaper because you don't
have the monies while you're calling
right
well I mean we have twenty three
thousand dollars in Saving oh so you can
ride a chicken by heat and air
wow well and you can probably pay off
some other debt with that money too
because you didn't need that much in
savings to begin with if you're in baby
step two
yeah I mean we have like two student
loans car payment and solar payment
so that was another thing if we were we
were thinking we should go snowball with
the lowest payments be the student loans
or just tackle the
the higher monthly payment which is a
car payment here's what I would do if I
were you you've got you said how much
was it 23 000 in savings savings yes
okay if I'm you I'm walking through the
baby steps simply I'm keeping a thousand
dollars aside that's your starter
emergency fund okay that's baby step one
baby step two we're doing the debt
snowball method with this method list
them smallest to largest by balance okay
not interest and then you're paying the
smallest one first you can use some of
this 23 000 to get your AC fixed
and then whatever is left throw it at
the smallest step what's your smallest
debt
uh sixteen thousand uh student loan all
right let's knock them out you can pay
that off today and then figure out what
how much you're going to have to spend
on the AC do we have to replace it you
need to get some other opinions or can
it be repaired and last two more years
because you need two more years to clean
up the rest of this mess or one more
year or whatever it is and so I'd rather
repair it until you're out of debt if
that's possible I couldn't understand if
her Psy was a sigh of relief or a sigh
of frustration or a sigh of irritation
yeah well you're maybe you're in a house
that's 100 degrees with no air yeah it's
irritation but it's not at us um yeah so
right I would repair I did repair when I
was in your situation a heating and air
unit
um and um really pitifully repaired it
but it made it through uh into winter
and then we made it into the next summer
and uh by then we cleaned up a bunch of
the mess and we were able to pay cash to
put a new heat and air unit in
um and so the problem is you cannot
allow yourself to live from crisis to
crisis you have to live from plan to
plan
and so let's set aside a little bit of
money and fix the heat in there or
replace it and let's use the rest of the
23 000 except for one thousand dollars
pay off your student loan today and then
start paying on the other things very
aggressively get on a budget on every
dollar the app it's the world's best
budgeting tool it's called every dollar
you can get it for free get on that and
she's probably gonna find what nine
percent nine percent is what the average
person finds in their income extra yeah
when you start doing a budget you get a
nine percent raise which oddly enough is
very similar to the inflation rate under
hey okay it's almost like there's no
excuses now I love that so you get on a
budget and you make every dollar behave
you quit eating out you quit going on
vacation and you get your dad gum mesh
cleaned up so that next time a little
three thousand dollar thing happens it
does it's not the end of the world for
you that's right and let's get this mess
cleaned up get this car paid off use my
promo code when you do it go to
everydollar.com Jade and get 15 oh fool
there you go I don't still don't have a
slash Dave you got to know how to pull
the strings Dave slash Jade every dollar
slash J that's right hmm
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Tim is in Boston hey Tim what's up
hi Dave
I'm uh 37 with a wife and three young
boys
um and two years ago I received a
terminal cancer diagnosis
um and thankfully I had a term life
insurance policy in place and I'm
wondering would it ever make sense to
convert my Term Policy to a whole life
policy
trying to understand all the angles wow
I'm sorry you're going through that
it's how you doing
I'm alive and um
I am
thrown everything I can at it and so far
I've been you know
um in Uncharted Territory this is what
my doctors say
um
prognosis can be pretty Grim
um but I'm trying some experimental
treatments overseas and with some
collaboration here in Boston has some
great hospitals so I'm getting great
care
um but I do have part of my question
where a lot of squirrels are on paying
for some out-of-pocket expenses so my um
Term Policy being converted the whole
life is related to tapping into some of
that
sooner
um Lord willing that continues to work
but there's no category of remission for
my type of cancer
um
all right what is the rest of your money
situation
yeah I
we're doing well I am on disability
and thankfully thanks in large part to
education I received for your teaching I
also had long-term disability with a uh
you know private plan in addition to the
term life that covered some of the Gap
um and I now sort of my job is domestic
and enabling my wife to work so she now
is a full-time athletic director so
you know we we probably take in
um
how much uh so you got the income
covered how much of a nest egg is there
we have a
um you know around 300 something 300K in
my uh
403 b and how much how much debt do you
have
we have no Consumer Debt unless you own
your mortgage mortgage how much is a
mortgage we probably have around 500
000 what's your wife making
she makes around 70. okay and what's the
term policy how much
um two million dollar death benefit okay
yep and what's the how much longer is
left on the term
yeah so I have North Northwestern Mutual
is 80
um so I have plenty of Runway with
um you know if I continue to renew it
um I'll have until you know I pass or
80. oh okay so it's renewable until
you're 80 years old but does it grow up
does it go up every year or how often
does it go up it goes up but it really
isn't I mean since I'm so young it's not
going to go up anytime yeah you know
okay all right so all right now so
here's the thing converting term life
insurance to whole life life insurance
does not make you money it costs you
money yeah
okay it's not a good Savings Program
um and it's going to go up
considerably
um in general now I mean I don't know
within the Northwestern Mutual their
term insurance is high to start with but
you're stuck with it you got it now if
you so but in general term is about five
percent is expensive five dollars per
hundred thousand as as whole life and
whole life builds up a savings but you
don't need an extra expense right now to
build up a savings inside of an
insurance policy so converting this to
whole life doesn't do anything for you
are you referring to the premium but
yeah
so that I guess
um
it gets maybe even to the more of the
heart of my question if I had a waiver
on that premium which would be the
disability waiver yeah yeah would that
change the dynamic it I don't think you
can convert to a whole life and the way
you're apply because the whole life is
is 20 times more expensive yeah so I
think that's one of the things my
financial advisor brought to my
attention is we put a retainer on
through my disability that would cover
about a 35
000 annual premium yeah
well if they're paying it
because of this but I I got to tell you
I'm pretty suspect of that because your
financial advisor is not a financial
advisor your financial advisor is a
Northwestern Mutual Life Insurance
salesman sure that's who they are and
um and uh I mean you've got the you've
got the term policy I certainly don't
want to do anything that screws that up
and the premium is being paid today
um and so you buy the by the um by the
disability writer correct
correct yeah because you've been
declared disabled I I Tim I'm not gonna
mess with it
okay I'm not because I I have had so
many bad experiences with these
companies over the years that uh they
don't follow through on things and
everything's not what they say it is and
it changes in the middle of the dadgum
thing and right now what I've got is
um
you're you're describing to me that you
that you're going to be in heaven and
your wife is going to have two million
dollars plus three hundred thousand and
she's got a 500 000 mortgage your wife
and kids are your wife and boys are in
financially and going to be in really
good shape
that's what you're describing to me
right now and I just don't mess with
that
no I don't I'm trying to understand all
the Angles and I if I didn't see I mean
we reviewed the contract the other day
and I mean it very clearly states that
Northwestern Mutual pay the annual
premium for the conversion yeah every
year for Hawaii
I mean
for
until you're 80.
yeah I mean
I'll tell you you need to have an
attorney look at this
okay how are you doing I I just don't
trust them I'm sorry I I've just dealt
with that industry for so long and I
don't think your personal agent wouldn't
necessarily mislead you I just don't
trust the industry you follow me I'm not
suggesting that your guy is a bad guy
necessarily
um uh but that is some crappy insurance
with a crappy company and uh right now I
got two million dollars for your wife
and boys and I sure don't want to screw
that up uh in order to get you know uh
to to take your premium way up and then
pay it if they're going to pay the
premium and it puts some cash value in
your hands that you can use to help
fight this cancer and you can get an
attorney to convince you that that's
true I can't argue against that I'm just
very cynical working with these people
so until you've had an attorney review
this contract and you've got some
outside counsel outside of a life
insurance agent I wouldn't do it but if
you do that and you come to the same
conclusion I won't argue with you this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
mitches in Washington DC hi Mitch
welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks for having me how y'all doing
today better than we deserve what's up
so my wife and I recently went under
contract on a house and we're excited
but as two people that have pretty much
adhered to a debt-free lifestyle we're
nervous about taking out a mortgage on
the property no real estate's a great
investment but we're nervous to take out
a chunk of our savings for the cashew
and clothes and even more nervous about
the monthly payment on the mortgage
should I press ahead and take on that
better hit pause and rethink things
well it depends on what's giving you
pause about this is it because the
payment is a big portion of your income
every month I mean what percentage of
your income is it tapping into every
month so my wife and I do we do that 215
000 a year between the two of us and the
house the mortgage to get the house will
sold for 7.75 we're putting five percent
down so it's going to be a big check
more than 25 percent
yeah of your take-home pay
probably
that might be why you're feeling this
because at the end of the day right when
you have your mortgage you want it to
you want to feel good about it right you
want to know okay I can pay the mortgage
I also have plenty of uh spread here to
do everything else that I need to do
because let's let's just break down the
numbers here okay most people they're
wanting to put 10 some sort of giving
right at some point you're going to want
to put 15 aside for your investing and
that then you've got this 25 mortgage
payment you're already at 50 so if that
mortgage payment Creeps in you know 30
40 you're going to start feeling that
pinch very quickly and my guess is
that's probably where you're at how much
money you got in savings
uh between the two of us about ninety
thousand dollars
okay and you're putting most of that
down
uh we're putting about 56 000 of it down
and keeping a little bit left over just
for a rainy day okay and you have no
other debt
no zero debt except for student loans
but I haven't paid on those since the
pandemic
and I'm a federal employee so they're
going to be forgiven soon anyway
no they're not
there's not a program to forgive student
loans
that's actually working
what do you mean who told you you're
lonely I thought if you were if you were
a federal employee after a number of
years of federal service they actually
forgave your balance of your loans I
think it's 10 or 15 years of federal
service yeah it's 10 years and so far 97
of the people that have made application
for that have not gotten their
forgiveness we literally ran the numbers
me and some folks who work here in
research Department ran the numbers on
that yesterday it's 1.97 percent
other people other people that apply
actually near forgiveness
I hate to say it how much is your
student loan debt
uh it's probably 80 to 100 000 between
the two of us okay
all right
um
well
you have signed a contract and so you're
in this deal unless you are not approved
for the mortgage so you will keep your
word I'll never tell people to break
their word but if we were to coach you
uh before you got into all of this we
would tell you to become debt free
student loans and everything before you
purchased a home uh a government plan to
forgive your student loans is
um
statistically irrational it doesn't
occur and
um so we want you to clear I would want
you as a method of best method of
building the best possible life with the
most wealth is to clear all debt
including student loans as soon as
possible have an emergency fund plus a
down payment so you would not be in a
position to buy a home today if you had
come to us before you were under
contract now that you're under contract
make sure that the home is a 15-year
mortgage not that is no more than 25
percent of your take-home pay and
take-home pay being not after 401K but
just after taxes after taxes and
um and are you putting money into your
401ks right now
yes yes I am okay in your situation if
you go ahead and close on the house or
if you don't stop that temporarily until
you get these student loans cleared
because the best thing you can do for
your future is to clear these student
loans as soon as possible
um and and then let's keep the home
payment on a 15-year fixed where it's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
after taxes not after health insurance
not after uh car payment coming out for
the credit union not after uh 401k and
all that but just after taxes what's
your take-home pay and is your payment
going to be more than that and um so
yeah
um that that's how we would tell you to
do it using what we call the baby steps
which has helped more people get out of
debt and become wealthy than any other
system so far right now in America
certainly more than 1.6 percent of the
people that attempt it well here's the
thing when he took out the when he made
an offer on this house we don't know if
he planned on getting a 15-year or a 30
year I sure hope he planned on a 15 year
he's going to be up a creek without a
paddle well I mean it just it probably
doesn't state that in the contract it
just says to be approved for financing
yeah that's true and if you're not
approved for financing because you say I
will only do a 15-year then you would be
out of the deal oh well and then you
would write a check and pay off your
student loans and you would rent for a
little while longer until you get your
self in a position to actually yeah
purchase
this is the problem folks it gets us
just so angry around here we can't
breathe because we love you guys and we
want you to win and when you believe
lies about your money yeah that cost you
Decades of your life
it it it disturbs us because we want you
to win and here's one of these lies just
very casually
as if as if it was just a stated known
fact oh well they'll get forgotten I
don't have to worry about those student
loans they're forgiven and and then to
come to find out they're not and it's a
lot of them too
1.6 of people get to the 10-year mark
under that program are actually getting
forgiveness yeah and then there's the
new 30-year Mo program which is going to
end up being worse only you will be 20
years further into yeah it's not good
meantime you've sat on this egg and sat
on this egg and sat on this egg and when
it hatches
it's a monster a monster in the egg it
wasn't a goose it was a monster
no Goose laying any golden eggs in there
a little a little goonie comes out
that's so true
and you know that's that's infuriates me
that the government has continued to
spread this crap and that people on
these hope Stealers on the internet
continue to spread this crap to the and
people believe it and when you believe
it when you believe a lie and you act on
a lie it always causes you to stub your
toe have a bloody nose and a black eye
it always causes that oh Bliss is hard
I'm so sorry for him yeah that's that's
tough I was talking to a reporter today
that doesn't like that right
I was talking to a reporter today and I
said to him I said everybody's
complaining about the interest rates in
the whole housing market oh it's so hard
to buy a house today but these are the
same people Dave who are fine with and
doing what this guy's doing what's I
only have eighty a hundred thousand
dollars debt I'm fine with keeping that
there I'm like do you don't see if you
don't see how that's affecting your
ability to purchase a home and have
peace about it that's one of the reasons
this is all related because
even if the forgiveness is hanging out
the only way the forgiveness if it did
happen is if you continue to make the
payment
so that's that's possible putting the
squeeze on the dadgum budgets 100 000
student loan yeah that's where the
that's why you're feeling pinched you're
exactly right but even if even if you're
one of these people who says oh I'm
gonna get the lowest payment possible
you're gonna tell me that you're gonna
move into a brand new 775
000 house
and that hundred thousand dollars of
student loans isn't gonna strangle you
with its presence every night yeah yeah
now there's a goonie you're sitting here
there's a little monster in that egg
it's like when uh we've all been there
right you're you know somebody's coming
over to the house and your house is a
mess oh my my parents in law my
mother-in-law's coming over so you slide
everything in the closet real quick how
come it's always the in-laws with you
okay look I don't know
[Laughter]
they're all into the closet and you
think it's clean but you know what's
really in that closet and you know it's
got to get dealt with and there's a
lumpy rug it's got somebody swap
something under the rug that's right the
old metaphor is true and thus there's a
lump
some of you got lumpy rugs
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their why
action guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
50 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free
John is with us hey John how are you
doing great Dave thanks for having me
honored to have you sir where do you
live Amarillo Texas well welcome to
Nashville all the way here to do a debt
free scream how much did you pay off
eighty three thousand dollars how long
did this take just 17 months wow and
your range of income during that time
about 120 to 150. good for you what do
you do for a living I am a traveling
occupational therapist oh very good good
for you what kind of debt was the 83 000
all student loans uh you killed it
that's what I'm talking about it's kind
of odd we just took a call from a guy
with 80 000 in student loans it was
going to be magically forgiven okay
John's were magically forgiven when he
paid them turns out you can honestly
just pay him yourself look at that way
to go who knew way to go man I'm proud
of you congratulations the taxpayers of
America thank you yes very good very
good good stuff all right so you just
got out of school yep that's right and
so uh you got your occupational therapy
uh degree past the boards and boom
you're off to and you catch the travel
which is the highest paid possibility
that's right that's right and uh they
also cover some of your uh food and
lodging they cover everything so you
just throw even more money at this so
you just went on the road said I'm gonna
be a gypsy and we'll knock this out yeah
you got it proud of you man well done
well done was it worth that extra
struggle absolutely absolutely when I
first started or when I first finished
the school I did interview
um for a reg alert job you know like a
regular working in a hospital and it was
pretty much half the income wow and I
looked at the numbers and I said that's
not gonna work for me so I went the
traveling route wow good for you how
much longer will you do travel will you
come off the road now that you got this
done well my plan is actually to
continue for two to three more years so
I can complete uh three and three B and
then pay cash for a house hey that's
awesome look at you man that's fun I
kind of want to get in your head a
little bit because you know you go to
school you're like okay I know I've got
this debt coming up what made you look
at this and say I I've got to take
responsibility for this I've got to pay
it off why why did you not jump on the
Forgiveness bandwagon jump on all this I
don't really have to pay it back
bandwagon why why are you different I
need to understand that well I think it
goes back to I can't call myself
necessarily a financial peace baby but I
grew up in a house my parents actually
LED Crown Financial Ministries
and so
um I was familiar with that is dumb cash
is King but
when I was going through my bachelor's
and then I decided to pursue a master's
I didn't have a plan on how to pay for
it I was focused on getting into school
and then the time came and I was like oh
what is there to do you know you've got
Pell Grant scholarships financial aid
when you fill out the um uh the FAFSA or
the financial aid they use terms like
assistance and
um this is alone yeah so that's right I
fill out everything and then at the end
it's like oh here's your agreement
here's your interest rate oh can you
just sign and then so I was like okay
well I I guess I got a sign you know
that's the only way because I didn't
have a plan for it you have the
information about that but by the time
you got out she had a plan it's called
travel that's right that's right and
then there was that thing no are you
going to any cool places when you travel
or just places that nobody wants to go
to well I wanted to go to the places
that paid the most okay and that's the
places nobody wants to go to okay yeah
good for you so nothing fancy then no
not really nothing nothing cool like I
got to go to this and I got to do that
and no we're working we're working okay
good for you well done how's it feel s
great it feels amazing
um actually I had so I paid off all my
last payment
the day after my 28th birthday and then
two weeks later my vehicle caught fire
of course it did
yeah to celebrate yeah
but as I was standing on the side of the
road and I actually work in home health
care so I drive to see my clients and so
I'm standing on the side of the road
waiting for the tow truck and it's hot
out
and I've I'm okay it's fine like I'll be
okay
peace insurance I'm sure that covered
the vehicle right and on top of that
we've got some money and we don't have
any debt so we'll just get into the cart
all right good for you man well done
amazing I I'm just so what do you tell
the person I mean you said you paid it
off a couple of days after your 28th
birthday what do you tell the person
who's listening who's 38
and they've got 83 000 in student loans
what do you say to them
don't wait you know George Campbell
always says what's the best day to plant
a tree and it's 25 years ago and then
the next best day is today so just start
now like you know you can you can wait
around for Washington and and the
politicians will change you know but you
can you can the lives don't change much
but the politicians change yeah so don't
wait just you know you're in charge of
your future go for it come on I love it
John on this is great man I'm so happy
our hero man I'm so proud of you all
right now uh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you're
someone who actually did it you paid off
eighty three thousand dollars in 17
months what's the key
well you need the budget obviously and I
use every dollar and it's it's wonderful
it makes things so easy but you also the
budget also gives you peace because you
have your your groceries your gas
everything's covered so if you know
you've got the money for it you don't
have to stress you can just focus on
paying off the debt but more importantly
one of the things I learned because I
did do a little side hustling
um delivered packages for Amazon and you
know these side hustles they help you
stay in the game you know if you work
your nine to five and then you go home
on the weekends we're constantly
bombarded with advertisements and
consumerism and everybody's trying to
get your money well if you go to work
not only are you not spending money but
you're also earning money so you get
like a double-edged sword
when it comes to the side hustle it
distracts me from spending when I work
more are you sure you you're in
occupational therapy and not in finance
because you you're talking the talk you
nailed it you nailed it man well wow
that's beautiful very cool proud of you
man thank you so uh who's this
cheerleading crew you brought with you
uh my brother and his wife and my
parents as well other family members
couldn't make it but they're watching
yeah and Sharon Young so you had a good
good you had good support good
background absolutely lots of people
cheering you on going yes yes yes clean
it up clean it up you can do it you can
do it and that's very good how'd you get
connected to Ramsey well growing up when
I was even younger uh dad used to listen
to talk radio and there's that guy with
that accent yelling at people to pay off
their debt and so I don't know
but uh yeah I just always know Ramsay
was just kind of like the name in the
household you know everybody knew when
you graduated you got The Total Money
Makeover or when you got married that's
what my parents would give as as gifts
to other people so I like your parents
that's good good stuff so great we got
the live and give box for you it's the
baby steps millionaires book which is
your next step for sure you're heading
that way congratulations sir you're a
very sharp young man you're a hero you
took control of your life it's got The
Total Money Makeover book which uh
apparently your family gives away all
the time so you'll be able to do that
and the Financial Peace University uh a
membership to that go through it or give
it away whatever you want to do it's all
for you to live and to give and thanks
for making the trip all the way in to do
this Dead free scream we appreciate you
you're an inspiration sir very very well
done John from Amarillo Texas
83 000
pound let's hear a debt free scream
three two one I'm dead
[Applause]
that's how they do it in Texas boys and
girls I like it I like it a lot yes very
well done
so when you work more
you don't spend as much because you
don't have time to sit and doom scroll
Amazon that's a fact Doom scroll
influencers trying to Pedal you crap you
don't need
you don't have a chance because let me
tell you there's a direct correlation
between the amount of time you spend on
the internet and the amount of money you
spend what's uh idle time is the devil's
workshop good that's it now internet
time yeah that's it is the devil's
workshop for sure advertisers Workshop
let's see Advertiser Workshop they're
going to get you the longer you're on
there the more likely you yeah there's a
lot of hooks in this pond fish just
saying this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today
you heard that debt free screamer John
talk about how important the budget is
and he was using the every dollar budget
uh Jade and Rachel and George Campbell
are all doing budgeting
webinars that are free teaching you how
to budget how to handle an irregular
income how to do actually integrate the
baby steps into your budget how to get
ready for Christmas how to get ready for
October 1st if you've got a student loan
all of these things are going to be
covered in these budgeting webinars if
you want to register for one of them
they're free you interact with them Jade
answers questions Rachel answers
questions George whoever's doing it you
can figure that out you just go to
everydollar.com budgeting and you did
one yesterday I did I did one yesterday
we had over 5 000 signups it was
incredible wow very good yeah you know
some of these have had five and ten
thousand sign ups and again it's
completely free it's us helping you
showing you the every dollar budget app
how it works and uh man be sure you
check it out yeah and let me just
because I think sometimes Dave we say
the word budget and people have this
thing in their mind of what it is but I
don't think people understand all the
feature teachers that are part of this
this idea that you can pay plan your
paychecks you can literally go in and
schedule when you want to make payments
when you want to spend the money that's
basic planning tool for inside the month
yes is a big it actually makes it work
it's amazing to me that's one of the
missing pieces and then there's the
financial roadmap which I think anybody
who's listened to this show and it's
like okay I know I'm supposed to pay off
my debt but if I pay off my debt at what
point will I be able to save my
emergency fund and then at what point
can I buy home it calculates all that
for you all of it it'll protect your net
worth it'll project when you could be a
millionaire it'll project when you'll
have your down payment saved come on you
guys need this yeah but it's also going
to project and kick your butt that's
right and make you do this stuff too oh
yeah there's that part so be sure and
check it out free webinars
everydollar.com budgeting Jade's doing
them Rachel Cruz is doing them George
Campbell's doing them and like I said
Jade had one yesterday five thousand
folks hers two weeks ago was ten
thousand that's right so I jump in there
you can be part of this we interact with
you we answer questions the questions
pop up you all work them into the talk
right that's right oh yeah we hear
directly from you guys so Jump On It
Marnie is in Salt Lake City if I push
the right button that is uh there's
Marnie hi Marnie how are you
hi Dave and Jade thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so I recently graduated law school good
for you and I thank you
um I'm single I'm a full-time single mom
and I have two kids
and I'm 40 and don't have a house so
we're just been renting
and so I have some money that I've been
saving it's been set aside to buy a
house
um but I'm wondering because now now
that we're finally here Dave felt like
it would never come
but I'm wondering if I I really want to
do my own practice
and so I'm wondering if it's okay to
take money from that
for my savings to like start my own
practice instead of like getting a
regular nine-to-five job
as a lawyer you passed your bar
I'm still waiting to find out so I don't
know yet and you um you got out of law
school with no student loan debt
correct okay any debt at all
no how much how much money is in this
pile
um about sixty four thousand
and you're 40 years old
yes
uh
hmm
my age scares me because I only have
about so in addition to that I only have
about 17 000. you're talking to a 63
year old your age doesn't scare me
well I mean it makes me nervous not
having a lot for retirement not having a
home like and just wow
you're amazing I mean you're a single
mom from law school and passed the bar
oh my gosh look at you no debt I'm at 40
years old you you know you're like a
superhero
I love people going business for
themselves I've been in business for
myself my whole life so I love the
entrepreneurial aspect of this
um and for some reason I'm kind of
wanting you to take a job for a little
bit and just kind of I think I want you
to learn how to be a lawyer mm-hmm
before you open a law practice and law
school doesn't teach you how to be a
lawyer it teaches you how to it teaches
you how to pass tests about the law
foreign
and there's a difference when you
actually go into a courtroom and then
what versus when you did a mock trial in
law school there's a difference when you
actually sit down with someone and they
look at you and say I want to get a
divorce and you're my gal that's going
to do it and you're actually dealing
with and I and I gotta you got to put a
restraining order because this guy's
beating me when you really have that
happen and you're actually being a
lawyer that's different than and you're
running a business which you've never
done before too that's different than
what you've done so far so far you've
learned how to take tests about the law
so I think I want you to learn how to be
a lawyer before you want to learn how to
be a lawyer and run a business at the
same time
but I I maybe I'm being too conservative
well I was planning on I'm hiring like a
law coach for part of
like so they have business and then like
coaches that will help you open yeah
you know you can have a you can have a
personal trainer but until you actually
do the exercises
you haven't done the exercises and if
you go work for a law firm you're going
to get the benefit of that
just by look working at the law firm
you're gonna learn how to like Dave said
you're going to learn how to do this
you're not gonna have to pay somebody to
teach you best practices because you're
going to learn that I'm fine if you do
it but the problem you're going to have
if you open the business and I'm 50 50
because I love the idea of opening a
businesses you have to learn how to
business and run a business and you have
to learn how to practice law all at the
same time and 64 000 is not much cushion
you need to make some money
and you can go make you know what 80 100
000 bucks out of the gate right now
working for somebody and just start
stacking some more cash and learning how
the law and and watch how they're
running their business at that law firm
because running a law firm is running a
business yeah
you know you still have to pay people
you still have to you know if you've got
a receptionist you have to hold withhold
taxes you've still got to manage the
banking you've got to do all these
things while you practice law it's a
totally different skill set yeah and so
I you know
uh either one is okay but I'm just
giving you a warning that it's it's not
going to be all Skittles and rainbow you
got two up two more Hills to climb
and you have to learn how to run the
business
I'm going to send you a copy of the
entree leadership book uh our number one
bestseller on how we run this business
it's our Playbook and the
entrepreneurship materials are how to
run a business stuff I do that podcast
uh every week as well and you can tune
in and listen to that but it's um that's
about running a business a small
business a law of a small Law Firm is a
small business so uh yeah if you're
gonna do it plug in plan on learning
two skill sets that you don't have yet
being a lawyer is different than you
graduated from law school and running a
business is different than being a
lawyer so those are two additional skill
sets and it's just it's scaring me a
little bit for you I I you've worked so
hard I want you to have some Prosperity
there's just no I can't see downside to
working even just a couple of years at a
firm
yeah except if you get uh if you lose
your
the power of the dream
and you get stuck in the Rut or you get
you get low you get lulled to sleep well
if a true a true business owner would
not get lulled to sleep a true business
owner would be like I can't take this
I've got to go I gotta get out here I
gotta do my thing I got I mean I I might
say I might make that argument no that's
true that's true but it's yeah I
either one is okay if you're gonna go
the Open The Firm I'm telling you these
are it's more of an uphill climb than I
think you
anticipate so I'm just warning you
you're you're signing on for another
tough run and you've been through enough
tough runs for a while to suit me yeah
so um yeah it's okay to work somewhere
for three years and then open your firm
that you'll only be 43. and and shut up
about being old there's part of that too
you know her if she were to go into
business for herself that's not her
immediately going out renting an office
space immediately going out yeah because
you gotta get money coming in well I
mean because she run it out of her is
there it no you know you have to have a
Commercial location oh oh it's not
that's even look I'm that's even more 64
000 bucks is gonna go fast that's even
more checks on the other side of the box
for me gotta go fast this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
the phone number here is AAA
825-5225 it is a free call and we are
glad you are with us Justin is starting
off this hour he's in Knoxville hi
Justin welcome to the show
hey Mr Ramsay thanks for having me on
sure what's up
um
long story short I've been put in charge
of
um my Mom's finances and um I have to
decide on what to do and um I came up
between
um
a few different options
um and I don't really know what the best
thing to do
at this time would be
um
basically it's 325
000 and um
I don't know if it's best to
um put it into a real estate like a um a
rental home or
I guess also commercial real estate like
for like um maybe a storage thing or
something like that or if the stock
market is the best thing
I've been kind of told both and I I
didn't really know which one would be
best
how old is your mom
um if I do the math I think it was 53
but she's been saying 32 for a couple
decades now
[Laughter]
how do you end up in charge of a 53 year
old
my um Dad passed suddenly a couple
months ago and um
so
it was a and he didn't have any
retirement he had cancer
um he passed away up but he had cancer
and so all of his retirement and savings
and all of that was wiped out a long
time ago so
um
I wasn't banking for about five years
before I got to where I'm at now why is
your mom not able to take care of her
own money at 53 years old
it's just more of that since I had more
experience with it and she's also kind
of going through some physical issues
right now that
she thought it'd be best to just ask me
so we're actually working on it
um together it's not like come you know
the way you were describing it initially
it sounds like she was 89 and was a
Dementia or something is she working and
everything else is
going along like normal
she was working but she had a couple
medical issues come up so how is she
going to eat
um well as far as it goes they
um had a home and they're renting that
out
so she has been so she has that and
she's been living with her parents
um but yeah so as far as it goes I was
just trying to figure out what to do
with kind of um well it affects it
affects what to do long term if we don't
have short-term covered and short term
you have a 53 year old living with her
parents now
and her only income is the income off of
one rental property what is that income
almost exactly 2 000 a month okay
wow
all right are you married
yes okay
your wife's gonna get tired of this
well they're best friends so yeah it'll
take a while yeah it's going to take a
you know over the next 30 Years this is
going to take a toll
so I'm really going to suggest that
you're that you assist your mom creating
an emotionally uh sustainable situation
where she's like a grown-up
yeah
um well it doesn't sound like it right
now it sounds like everyone's taking
care of her you her parents everyone
else and she's sitting over here living
on two thousand dollars a month doesn't
have a job doesn't have a career doesn't
have any aspirations I know you just
lost your dad I'm sorry for that I'm not
trying to be insensitive but I want your
mom to create an emotionally sustainable
and prospering flourishing life for
herself where she is an amazing woman to
be reckoned with not a kept woman whose
daughter-in-law secretly resents her all
the time her husband spends with his
mother and so uh this could happen it
may not but it could happen and I I just
I want better things for your mom than
this so to answer your your basic
question though of what would I do no
you don't take 325 000 and put this lady
in a rental property the last thing she
needs is to be dealing with renters she
can't deal with life
you don't need to be taking on rental
property for her you don't need to add
to your burden so if I'm in your shoes
I'm going to sit down with a good
smartvester Pro there's several of them
there in Knoxville with your mother and
uh lay out a game plan that she approves
of and understands where that money is
invested and left alone if she will
leave it alone in good growth stock
mutual funds it will double every seven
years or so
so she's 54 at 61.
she will have uh 750 000 at 68 she will
have 1.5 million so she'll be just fine
with that and the rental property but
she needs to create a sustainable life
uh that is good for her mental health
where she's prospering and growing and
engaging and getting Traction in life
again I mean at reasonable amounts of
time to grieve obviously we lost your
dad and I'm again I I want her to agree
with all that but the way you're setting
this up is a sustained caretaking of
someone that shouldn't need caretaking
that's the way your voice is when he
first started talking about her I
thought she was in a nursing home yeah
89 years old yeah yeah and that's the
words you're using Justin and I don't
want those words for your mom at 53. yes
there's a lot of Life to Live it's a
bright sunshiny day outside you know I
really I wanted to I want her to feel
all of that again and uh I mean she may
go meet some amazing man and get married
and really throw you off and some point
um so I mean I hope she does yeah really
I mean I don't know I I but I just want
her to have a lot more than well she's
gonna live with her mother yeah and
she's gonna because he's managing that
rental 25 000 last year I mean invest it
and keep her hands off of it help her do
that that's the answer to your question
but you as as usual when you call in
here you get more than you asked for
every time they know what they're
getting into Dave be careful what you
ask because I'm going to ask you things
about what you ask beware because uh
personal finance is as much personal as
it is finance and dealing with the
relational things is there so
yeah that was that was different yeah
ah yeah yeah that
hey man thank you for calling and thank
you for being son that steps up and
helps his mom yeah I appreciate you
doing that let's define help when you
say I'm helping my mom let's define help
very carefully
help includes encouragement to go be
somebody show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
August the 31st if you didn't know is
the last day of our month-long giveaway
Ramsey Solutions free money yeah that's
pretty cool 500 a week we've been doing
we'll do that today you can still
register if you're hearing this quickly
and uh grand prize up to three thousand
dollars will be a drawing later tonight
or tomorrow uh for the people that enter
today I guess it'll be tomorrow because
we'll give it till midnight tonight uh
for those of you not listening live this
is uh being done August the 31st a
Thursday so you got that
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
also get the deals that they run out
today at ramseysolutions.com in the
bookstore The Total Money Makeover uh
twelve dollars from paycheck to purpose
twelve dollars own your past change your
future twelve dollars a whole bunch of
our number one best-selling books twelve
dollars you can pre-order Dr John
deloney's brand new book that comes out
to October the 3rd and it's called
building a non-anxious life and you'll
learn the six daily choices to break
free from anxiety and uh if you
pre-order it for twenty dollars before
then including today you get 75 dollars
in free bonus items the questions for
humans conversation cards until the end
of the day today on sale for twelve
dollars all of this ends today did I
mention that at ramseysolutions.com
store raisin Miami hi Ray welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello Dave how are you thank you for
having me sure what's up
so I just started listening to the show
about two weeks ago and I had a good
amount of savings a combination of
savings along with a property that I
sold and I wanted to invest it but after
listening to the show I realized that I
should pay off my cars first so good for
you get off my cars yesterday paid off
both my cars how's that feeling I feel
weird
oh man you know what it's just a little
weight off my shoulders it's also good
yeah how much did you own your cars
I owed uh for both cars combined about
39 000 oh yeah yeah that's great that's
a big stroke after just two weeks to
listen to this weird stuff
all on board
so I I did that yesterday and I
basically moved from baby step six I
mean two all the way to six nice uh
because I have done everything else in
between
um so I had a little over a hundred
thousand uh saved I put the 40 towards
that roughly
and I want to know what to do next
um do I how aggressively do I go against
paying off my home I'm already paying
more than I'm supposed to but how
aggressively do I attack it to pay it
off in the next four and a half to five
years if I throw everything at it or do
I take some of that money and invest it
like I originally wanted to do because
I'm already
saving 10 percent to my 401k plus my
company's match was a six percent so
total of Sixteen percent okay
um my wife
is about three percent plus she's gonna
have a pension if I were you
you said your wife is three percent plus
a pension
yes he says he has a 403b and then she
also has her pension that she'll have to
teach for about another eight or nine
years yeah and you should get her
passion so that's good I think that with
the matches I wouldn't really count
those towards your 15 total I would just
keep that as gravy
um but with your with your wife so she's
got her three percent so maybe just a
two percent more I think to get that up
to 50 without the matches and then what
I would do you know if you most people
after they pay off their debt okay
they're paying off their home within
seven to ten years
that's kind of like the The Benchmark
that's the average if you're looking to
go at a four or five year rate if your
wife is cool with that and you both feel
good with that that's very intentional I
think that's a good rate you don't have
to be so intense that it's like oh we're
sacrificing everything to pay off our
home you're beyond that point and now is
the time to live a little be intentional
about paying off the house I would not
start investing more than 15 at this
point I would wait till the house is
paid off and then you can start putting
extra into your investment accounts not
counting the 60k do you have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
so that 60k left over is is part of my
emergency fund so I would probably a
part of what's the other part
I was going to invest 30 000 leave 30
000 for emergency okay okay and then and
then I was going to
either take whatever's left
towards more investing or paying off the
house and that's wait a minute there's
only 60. you did 30 and 30 already what
do you where do you have more than 60
somewhere else no I have 60 left that's
it period to your name you have 60 000
cash yeah
um maybe okay let's say 70 I have
another 10 000 in an account that's
enough maybe 80 because I have another
ten Thousand Miles
well I count that that's that's money
if you give it to me I'll count it so
let's count it okay so all right so
we've got we've got eighty thousand
dollars we need to set how much should
your emergency fund be
about about 30. okay so we're going to
take those two tens that are hanging out
there like loose strings and drop them
in an account that you never touch we're
going to add 10 from your 60 in there
and and that gives you 30 in an account
that you never touch except for
emergencies a separate account this
stuff kind of hanging out there in the
periphery is how it ends up getting
spent on a couch
okay and so if you want to spend on a
couch you save up and do that separate
from your emergency fund couches by
definition are never in an emergency so
uh so that you set that aside we got
that cleaned up so part of what we're
doing here is we're cleaning up you've
been doing a good job overall Ray you
were investing for retirement you had
this piece of ground you sold you made
some money you paid off the card I mean
you're really on track overall all I'm
doing is fine tuning I'm just polishing
a couple of little rough notches off
okay so let's get a total of 30 out of
the 80 in a separate account not to be
touched only for emergencies and if I
woke up in your shoes I would not invest
that I would throw that at your house
what's the balance on your home today
about 290. okay so that gets us to 240
and your household income is what
calm it's about 15 000 a month okay so
you're going to pay off 240 in about
four years probably without breaking a
sweat
right yeah I could I love it yes so I'm
throwing 50 at it with that in mind the
reason I'm doing that is then you're
sitting there with this fabulous 15 000
a month income and not a payment in the
world four years from today you will
become extremely wealthy starting to
invest some of that in addition to your
you know then you go back you max out
every account you can max out 401ks 403
B's put them all in mutual funds and
then once you Max that out you do some
side investing as well and you're going
to look up with 10 or 15 million dollars
in a few years because you're killing it
my concern is we're in our late 40s I'll
be I'm 47 next month my wife told you in
10 or 15 years you're gonna have 10
million dollars
wow
I think you're gonna be okay
I mean you're really doing good
you're really doing good and one of the
key elements people find is if you don't
give your money to the bank you have it
to invest so by clearing this mortgage
and that and including throwing this 50k
at it you're going the faster you clear
it the faster you don't have that
mortgage payment the faster you start
investing the equivalent of a mortgage
payment boom that turns into millions of
dollars in and of itself
guys just those of you out there
listening to this just go to one of
these financial calculators at there's
one in every dollar okay there is you
can use it in every dollar and just plug
in the simple thing what if I take my
house payments let's say your house
payment's twenty two hundred dollars
okay let's round it up after your house
payment's gone 2500 a month going in a
mutual fund at your age how fast does
that become a million dollars really
fast
just your house payment yeah
really fast I love looking at a an
investment calculator and plugging in
some numbers if you want to get
motivated do that yeah do that right
there I'll tell you it's exactly what
Sharon I did what that after we went
bankrupt the first liquid million
dollars not counting our home that we
had
came so quick because and I it caught me
off guard because I was playing a math
game in my head and I just wanted to see
what it would do so I took opened up a
separate mutual fund nothing to do with
my retirement after I was maxing out
retirement but the house was paid off
and I put 2 500 a month that's what it
was it is an old house payment in there
and I want just to see what that one
account it didn't have anything else
just the house how fast does the house
payment turn into a million dollars and
I didn't look at it again and I looked
up it felt like in two blinks and it was
a million dollars wow it was it's
amazing it's just amazing just amazing
how we could possibly retire broke in
America today it's amazing that you have
to
this is the Ramsay show yeah really
[Music]
foreign
thanks for joining us America Jade
wildshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host on the stage the debt free stage
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions Ryan
and Kate are with us hey guys how are
you hey Dave how are you welcome where
do you guys live uh just uh outside of
Boston Massachusetts a bit of a halt in
Nashville welcome down here thank you
good to have you I hope you have a good
time on you here how much debt did you
guys pay off we paid off um just over
100 well just under 128 127 997 that's
128. yeah that's good I like it how long
did this take almost exactly four years
way to go okay good for you and uh your
range of income during that time we
started at 85 000 a year and now we are
sitting at about 2 30. nice
nice change so what do you all do for a
living
um so I'm retired Air Force a year ago
now I do um contractor work okay very
cool
um I've been running a daycare in our
home for the last four years okay so
what caused the jump from 85 to 2 30. uh
probably Brian's retirement the contract
you you got the you got great military
retirement that's a nice chunk and you
go make a bunch of money as a contractor
yes sir okay wow all right that's just
you kind of double tripled up yeah and
she also too uh she was hustling too
obviously doing daycare stuff uh not
just Monday through Friday but um on the
weekends as well she does respite care
for families that have special needs oh
wow wow so she does that and um yeah it
we make a lot of money doing doing that
stuff so that's amazing we've been we've
been busy four years yeah I can tell
what kind of debt was the 128. uh it was
a lot of student loans yeah about 95 000
mosquito loans some car loans in there
so
cards so you used this uh three years of
no interest time to get out of debt yes
sir standing around and watching hoping
somebody was going to do it for you yeah
part of the one percent you realize that
right yeah yeah so less than one percent
we we heard the uh you know the uh
government coming out saying oh you know
Biden's going to do this and I'm going
to forgive all that and we're like head
down keep working yeah
the noise that's right yeah because
before that um I've I've also been in
I've been in college since 2018 so
before the pandemic and the zero percent
interest we were kind of just paying
minimums and
um the balances were just growing and
growing and growing because the the
interest rate was there and then we just
kept on taking out more loans
for my school until we started your
program so wow wow good for you guys
congratulations guys so what makes you
start this four years ago
um Christmas of 2018 my parents gave all
four of us kids
um yearbook The Total Money Makeover for
Christmas and so ho ho ho I read it
right away and then I asked Ryan to read
it and and he did
um and I wanted to jump right on board
and he was a little hesitant I think he
was comfortable where we were at
um and we were kind of going back and
forth about it for a couple months and
then it just so happened that our base
was offering Financial Peace University
at the chapel so
I said why don't we just take the class
and see what happens and that was
February 2019 we took your class wow
she knew what was going to happen when
you went into that class well it just
kept popping up it seems like first
there's the book and then here's the
class that you can run but you can't
hide it sounds like it wasn't going away
so I might as well just give in just get
weird right that's right
very very cool so oh go ahead Dave
you're fine I was gonna say so what was
the thing that was like okay we have not
been doing this before we need to start
now was it getting your income up was it
the budget talk to that piece that
really had to change within your
lifestyle
I think for us it was just staring at
the dollar figure just a mountain of
debt in front of us and knowing uh or
not knowing how we're going to get out
of it
um and we really needed to get on the
same page with money in general it was
kind of
um we were just kind of coasting through
life not really focusing on our finances
and we both knew that this like big
student loan number was like hanging
over our heads and we were just kind of
pretending that it wasn't there
cool very good good for you guys I'm
proud of you thank you thank you how
long you've been married 12 years 12
years have you ever been dead free other
than this no no sir wow brought the
student loans in and kept them around
yes yeah how's it feel to be free
fantastic free it's a
there's like an air of peace in our
house and in our lives and
um you know we've been able to do so
much along the way
um our oldest graduated high school we
were able to
purchase her first car for her
um help her pay after after the pandemic
yeah she went to college for a little
bit but then
um with her we were intentional about
saying you know hey look if you don't
know what you want to do and you don't
have a reason to be in school don't go
to school you don't have to be like
everybody else and for God's sakes don't
wreck up student loans we just got rid
of well that's what God that's what got
me in trouble was you know everybody
said oh just go to college it's going to
be fine you're going to figure out what
you want to do and I never did and I had
all this debt and
um yeah it was it was a big burden to
carry around and then our two little
boys we ended up
um pulling them out of public school and
now we homeschool them so that's part of
kind of part of our journey as far as
you know post-pandemic homeschooling
um jumped on that bandwagon let's go we
have options when you pay off that debt
you start to the world kind of starts to
open up and you start to see man I could
try this I can do this you're no longer
working just to pay off debt right yes
this is a hard four years though it was
yeah it's very hard I mean you Bear Down
me these numbers you you were you were
cutting in yeah and we also we also cash
flowed my college degree so I'm about to
graduate with a graduate degree clinical
mental health counseling wow good for
you and so we've been able to you know
when we started your program we were
like okay that's it we're not taking on
any more student loans so in addition to
paying off all the debt we've been
paying cash for my college which was
another you know thirty thousand dollar
bill that's excellent yeah Wow way to go
guys congratulations thank you so very
proud of you all very very well done all
right what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
don't get into it in the first place
there's that but if you must trust the
process yeah probably stay the course I
think we've we've had a longer road than
some
um 48 months is real yeah and it's been
hard on our kids as far as you know they
see their friends going on fun trips and
taking vacations and
um you know doing day trips to the city
and going out to lunch and dinner for no
reason and we weren't doing any of that
and you know it's hard to look your
child in the face and say no I
understand your friend gets to go do all
this fun stuff but we're not and this is
why
um and so just it was hard to stay the
course that worked out for us she got a
car well I see I see your daughter is
this your daughter to the left she's
shaking her head like yes we did not do
any of that yes but I got a car
note to self I got a car yeah that's
pretty cool and she's doing great too
she you know she works full-time and
she's saving all her money and yeah
she'll pay cash for her next car and so
that's you know that's the biggest gift
that we can give our kids is just a
different future that's right than what
we had amen amen well hey I'm so proud
of you you changed everything yes you
changed your marriage you change your
future you change your kids lives this
is very cool it took a lot of courage
and a lot of hard work very well done we
got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you in the live
and give box because that's your next
step for sure and uh of course Total
Money Makeover so you can give it away
and interrupt somebody's life like
happened to you yep yeah and I'd love to
give a shout out to my parents they're
the reason that we are on your program
they are baby steps millionaires
um and so they're a huge inspiration for
us
um my brother is also on your on your
plan and
um my sister too doesn't have any any
debt wow our whole family you've changed
our whole family tree and it's really
thanks to them they started yeah
you know when I was in my 20s I love it
good for them Wow way to go proud of
them too good stuff very well done all
right it's Ryan and Kate Boston Mass and
uh 128 000 paid off in 48 months making
85 to 230 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
[Applause]
I love that yeah
man never gets old never gets old this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you foreign
Chronicles 15 7 but as for you be strong
and do not give up for your work will be
rewarded
Mary Kay Ash says it's far better to be
exhausted from success than to be rested
from failure
I gotta chill yeah that one's good all
right Carrie is with us in Tampa Florida
hi Carrie how are you
hi Dave oh my goodness it's an honor to
be on your show honored to have you how
can we help
I I'm really just looking for death
uh payments for my husband's franchise
that is now closed
ouch
how much on an SBA loan to buy a
franchise
um it was a total of two hundred and
twenty three thousand dollars okay what
kind of franchise yeah it was a moving
company
uh he kind of bought it at a premium
because it was already in existence and
and we really were under the impression
it would be successful and unfortunately
I don't know if it was just due to the
market at the time but
um it was really obvious after about a
year that it was it was not going to be
profitable
um anytime soon and so he was made the
decision to close it and it was a big it
was a big risk to begin with but um we
decided to go ahead and just close it
and move on
he does have a great job now that he
loves things what does he make
about 70 000 now what do you make
I make 48 000. okay
do you guys have any other debt
we don't well we have a very small car
loan remaining and our house payment
um
we have about 200 000 left on our house
are there any assets at all left over
from the business
from the business no you sold them or
what
yes everything was sold and wiped out
um the actual franchise itself is is the
is the brand still open
yes can you not sell that franchise to
someone
it wasn't going to be and
that I couldn't help us with that
wow why
um that's a good question I would
we asked the question at the time and it
was going to be a a very very long
process to even try to find a buyer and
I don't know honestly it just
I assume the franchisor has approval
over any buyer but even if you could
sell the thing for ten thousand bucks to
somebody that just wanted that franchise
because they're probably selling that
franchise to a brand new Frenchie
franchisee for a good deal more than
that correct
it's possible they they kind of just
dissolved it in our territory and it was
picked up by somebody else who's further
away
um
so you've lost your rights to it by now
then probably yes yes it was closed we
closed it in in February now closing it
is different than the actual franchise a
franchise is an element
that is actually a a right that you have
that you paid for
um right all right so it was it has
expired all right man well so you got
233 000 on 110.
yeah twenty three thousand dollars a
year is ten years
fifty thousand dollars a year it's five
years
what are you gonna do to get your income
up so it goes faster
hot
I'm not sure we're hoping
um we're hoping that his job so far it's
going well but what did he do before
this promotion uh he's in operations and
Logistics management and he's worked for
um he's worked for Amazon for a few
years and he worked for another company
for a few years
um what did he make before he quit and
started the franchise
he was making about one I was 109 109.
that sounds more like Logistics than 70.
yes yes
um and he lost that job in January 2021
um they had a lot of they had a a
restructuring in the in the businesses
yeah but the logistics world if he know
if he if he knows supply chain and he
knows how to lay that out that's a
six-figure income
yes you would you would think that no I
wouldn't think I know but right right
and you live in Tampa freaking Florida
there's Logistics there for sure
let me tell you Carrie here's what's
going on okay you guys got the crap beat
out of you and your husband's lost his
confidence and you have too
and he doesn't feel like he's worth what
he's actually worth
because of this failure
I need you guys for your sake to go get
him a job making 110. he needs to get
back in the marketplace with his
shoulders thrown back and a little
Swagger in his step again he's not a bad
guy he just made you guys just made a
mistake and bought a business that you
didn't know how to run and run it in the
ground and you've lost your butts but
that doesn't mean you're horrible people
or your dumb people or that suddenly
he's not worth 110 when he probably
actually is
at least one of the things I had to
recover from when I went broke and mine
was a lot more dramatic although there's
you know what is major surgery surgery
that happens to you what's minor surgery
surgery happened to somebody else right
so um yours is very dramatic for you I'm
sure and traumatic but one of the things
I had to recover from was I felt like an
idiot
I felt like I had no why should anybody
trust anything I ever think again
because I was so stinking arrogant
before it knocked me completely out of
the saddle
and um I don't think your husband was
that guy but but it's normal when you go
through this it's the death of a dream
and part of your soul dies when you
close that door and lock to turn the key
for the last time and walk away
that definitely sounds fair yeah yeah
and I I just I I want to give you
permission to grieve that but I also uh
want you to to to keep perspective on it
and him to keep perspective on it
because I think he took just something
to get a job and he's just kind of
curled up in the corner wounded right
now
we definitely definitely went through
that um we are hopeful for this job I
mean he he applied for jobs for almost a
year before he decided to open a
franchise and we're not we're on the
outskirts of Tampa we're not really in
Tampa so we weren't finding anything
um at all
um and so when this this opportunity
currently that he's working for came
along
um
he's really really enjoying the job and
we're hoping well I'm glad but you have
223 000 worth of debt and he needs to
make a lot more yeah well my my okay
that's how it's going to be done kiddo
I'm not gonna argue with you anymore
okay the thing is I understand where you
are I've been where you are I I'm sorry
that you've been through all this pain
um but yeah we we you know you've got a
the big math says you need to put fifty
thousand dollars a year on it and you
can do that with your current income if
you live on beans and rice and it's
going to take you five years
or you can increase your income by forty
thousand dollars and do this in three or
four years and not have to live on beans
and rice while you're doing it and I I
really think that there's a tie in here
you look when you get hit this hard you
look for a safe place to hide and human
nature does that you want to go back to
something or where I'm you know no risk
no like just I don't want to stick my
head up I'll get it knocked off again
you know I don't want to do that so
thank you for your call that's the
answer you take the 223 and you divide
it into the number of years you want to
fool with this and what have you got to
do what has to be true to make that
happen and part of that is healing from
this the rest of the way and
um you're making excuses you are and
part of that tells me you haven't healed
from this the rest of the way so you
shouldn't have asked if you didn't want
me to tell you that's true and guys let
me just tell you those of you in
business out there well business debt
doesn't count business debt is good debt
tell that to carry
all right you go take out a two hundred
thousand dollar loan to buy a business
you're in stupid land and you do that
with an SBA loan you're in super stupid
land because SBA is forever they do not
go away they're like a student loan
and I'm not saying Carrie's stupid I'm
just saying any of you that are thinking
about doing this you need to listen to
her call
because oh well I am We're Not Gonna
yeah well right debt only works when
debt works and that's never
you get your butt bit off here man
people you got to stop it you got to
stop it ouch
bless their hearts ain't a horrible
thing to go through I put this hour the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]